one of our favorite guests to the show a
man who brings the frenzy to his show
every day as the host of Pat McAfee Show
2.0 a two-time Pro Bowl punter
first-team all-pro of you can't say
former all-pro punter once an all-pro
punter always an all-pro punter Pat
McAfee here on the Rich Eisen show on
the NFL Network how are you Patrick I'm
fantastic after that incredible
introduction mr. Eisen thank you so much
for that also since we are talking
free-agent frenzy and the frantic behind
it all yes you could also say I was once
franchisee tagged in that introduction
but you didn't know worried you miss to
be here NFL Network is a great place to
be I appreciate this free agent frenzy
now when you were franchise tagged would
you say the franchise tag was placed on
you or slapped on you would you say it
was slap right in my face
definitely you were not slap what that
we were not pleased with the franchise
tagging you didn't want to be franchise
tagged as a poner no I was very excited
it was more money than I could have ever
imagined in my entire life all of my
contracts with the NFL were but it was
definitely put upon me like yeah you're
not going anywhere
no we're not negotiating with you
anymore we'll see if you have another
good year wait I'm right on the face
that's what happened but I loved it it
was a lot of guaranteed money made my
family very comfortable and it's just
the NFL is the league who never stops
giving just like it's doing today's with
massive amounts of Brinks trucks being
backed up into people's homes all over
the country right so are you in the city
of Pittsburgh right now the great city
of Pittsburgh Patrick I am city of
bridges okay so whatever you like what
Khomeini brothers Here I am right the
middle of it for WWE Monday Night Raw
and it is an electric place right now
with this Antonio Brown News what give
me the general sense of what fans are
thinking in Jersey R love the Ben
Roethlisberger love that he can sling
the ball all over the yard any yard very
excited that Antonio Brown is gone very
excited that les Bell is gone the
injures think that they were bringing a
lot of drama to the city they think that
the team is much more likeable now
although they might not be as talented
and even though they only got a third
and a fifth rounder for Antonio Brown
they still feel as if the Steelers have
won because they can move past
the Real Housewives of Pittsburgh
situation that was happening inside the
locker room I have no idea if that's
true or not because the Cleveland Browns
seem to be getting better and better
I'll be excited to see what happens in
the AFC North but hinders everywhere are
rejoicing for Antonio Brown being gone
and I'm not sure that's the right play
I'm not saying they're right at all but
they seem to be happy about it all being
over and moving forward what do you
think's happening in the locker room
there in Pittsburgh what do you think I
don't know managing egos I think you and
I have talked about this managing egos
is a huge part of the modern NFL I mean
with the way social media is everybody's
their own brand everybody's their own
business the ability to handle people
who are great at things is a huge part
of Management these days so I'm not sure
that'll scare away other superstars from
coming to the beautiful city of
Pittsburgh in the future I'm just
thinking that they're hoping that the
young stars like juju and whoever else
comes in to fill in it just takes a
different path but I think right now if
you look at this viewers organization
you'll be one that is historically great
a lot of wins they've got a passionate
fan base but here in the recent history
has been surrounded by drama due to not
being able to manage attitudes and
personalities and I think that's very
obvious and this next phase next era of
the Stellar's are going to be a very
impressive one we'll see how many more
years then Roethlisberger has thrown a
ball around here Pittsburgh well Pat
McAfee if as I said at the beginning of
this frenzy as well as my show the Rich
Eisen show as it's named and Antonio
Brown Instagram lived--and tweeted his
way in a way into the spot that he
wanted how is your social media campaign
to get you in the Monday Night Football
seat going right now Pat I think the
campaign went very well
you know it got you into a little bit of
trouble with Kurt Warner which I love
right we trended for 10 hours McAfee for
Monday Night Football our intel which
means my agent's told me yes that the
day after we trended for 10 hours there
was an entire meeting at ESPN for the
Monday Night Football position my name
was mentioned less than once so I was
the media campaign that we ran I think
the campaign was a good one but we're
not result oriented here I don't
but we definitely disrupted the whole
situation and you helped out immensely
with that so I'm thankful for you
forever
so you refer to in the past tense it's
over just because he asked me and held a
meeting in your question once Pat come
on you what are we doing come on
right listen sometimes you got to get
your ass out there and you find that in
dog you know sometimes you've got to do
that and we went for it there was a lot
of tweets there was a lot of action
there was a lot of movement but there's
literally nothing we can do if we're not
in the meeting I mean that's a pretty
important meeting to be a part of this
there if you're campaigning for a
position that people control and then
the people that control that are having
a meeting and they don't even met your
name that's gonna be tough keep
campaigning but I'm all about getting
back on the trail sending some tweets
out some characters some hashtags and
see if we can make Monday nights the
most electric night of football again
but it's not my decisions of you made
snow it's not yours either we just gotta
sit back and see what happens yeah just
and let the chips fall before I let you
go can we put up on the screen my
friends at the NFL Network put up on the
screen the top free agent punters cuz
punters are free agents too
Pat Bradley pinion Pat O'Donnell Ryan
Allen if you're if you're one a left
legged variety Jordan berry and Donnie
Jones what do you think of this class of
free agents for punters Pat okay so
Donny bag of bones Jones has enough swag
to carry and fill an entire locker room
he's also a Super Bowl champion who came
out of retirement big lefty hits the
ball high and far down the middle of the
field
so you're depending upon what you want
he only has one ball but it's a good
ball Ryan Allen has been in massive
situations so you know the butt hole
isn't going to pucker if you're in a big
box which is a big deal because there's
a lot of pressure on you Bradley pinion
has the ability to be a great punter he
hits the ball well it goes far I'm not
sure he's got into a consistency that
he's looking for we'll see if that
happens in a new spot San Francisco also
a very windy place Pat O'Donnell has
become a completely different punter he
eliminates returners he's not going to
put up the huge numbers but he's not
going to give up many return yards as
well I'll be excited to see what he does
and then there's the Australian bomber
Jordan berry who has a tenant of a leg
from Down Under but I don't know if he's
confident at the time being enough to
step on the field and do it every single
time
you get them a little bit of cash maybe
that builds the confidence there's a lot
of bombers out there ready to hit balls
on fourth downs I'll be excited to see
where the chips fall if we're talking in
Rich Eisen terms Thank You Pat bless you
sir your uh your man who should not give
up I just heard some analysis that's an
all for down analysis they call Landon
Collins a balk safety you are not a box
broadcaster sir if I may say wow that
makes me feel really good I'm about to
run through a brick wall here maybe send
out another tweet maybe I'll just go
camp outside of Bristol and see if
they'll take a call or a conversation
with me but rich I can't thank you
enough I'm not sure if Chris is in there
tell them I said well yes right there
thanks for having me back on NFL Network
the last time I was on here the show got
canceled right take care
well the brand has a cookie there's Pat
McAfee bringing the frenzy the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience